few of us can debate right that there's
an increase in depression anxiety and
suicide amongst young people I mean the
statistics are alarming the highest rate
increase of suicide in the United States
is girls 10 to 14 years old the number
of girls 10 to 14 years old
the number of suicides has tripled in
the past 15 years right girls also
engage in social media 40% more than
boys it's not a causal relationship but
there's a correlation that's probably
worth looking at we know we know about
bullying online when I was a kid and I
tripped over in the cafeteria everybody
laughed at me I was really embarrassed
they'd make fun of me for a day or two
and then it was done now somebody will
film it and it will last your entire
school career that has to affect
somebody's self-confidence and sense of
self the idea where all of our
validation now comes from the number of
likes the number of followers we have
has to have an impact on the way we
conduct ourselves in the world and the
way that we make friends and many many
people will report that they will admit
that though they may have fun with their
friends that they have many superficial
friendships that they don't actually lie
on their friends if they're going for
hard times like we cannot get away from
this we cannot get away from the fact
that more and more universities if you
some many private schools now not just
private schools many schools now for
young people now have wellness programs
and therapists for children for like 10
years old and 14 year olds not because
they think those kids are anything wrong
with them it's because the universities
are inheriting 18 and 19 year olds that
are struggling with wellness and coping
mechanisms so badly that they're
actually starting to address the issues
with the kids younger to teach them
coping mechanisms before they get to
college we cannot ignore these things
and though there are many factors like
the an excessive amount of finite
mindedness like the excessive focus on
short-term performance like the lack of
loyalty to employees in companies you
know companies constantly complain that
your generation doesn't offer any
loyalty to the come
I don't blame you why should you they
give you none they missed their their
their annual numbers and your your laid
off it's not a meritocracy nothing
personal it's just business right why
should you give to boil tea if they give
you nothing so I think we cannot ignore
these factors of which one of them of
course has to be the imbalance of social
media and cell phones in our lives I'm
not against it I'm against the amount of
it right that that we can't go for
dinner with a friend and put our phone
in airplane mode for an hour and a half
and just be present with our friends and
so how do we combat this imbalance we do
more yoga like you've got to be kidding
me
right like no amount of yoga will fit
work/life imbalance I personally hate
yoga so I understand I mean you know and
what we forgot I mean it's a very
American thing that we've done which is
we've taken these wonderful Eastern
philosophies like yoga and meditation
and we've actually made them selfish
pursuits right I went to this big
meeting one so it was a small meeting
actually I went to the small meeting
once and though there was a person
sitting next to me who was apparently a
big tiny yoga instructor the entire time
we were in the meeting she was on her
cell phone under the table and it wasn't
like she had a family member in hospital
and she was checking and I could see she
was in social media right and at one
point the conversation went - we were
talking about being present and she
poked she poked up she perked up and she
goes that's why I love yoga it helps me
be present right being present doesn't
mean you pay $35 and you feel good about
yourself for one hour right that's not
what being present means you do not get
to say when you're being present you are
present when somebody else says you are
and the reason we meditate for example
is because we learn things like calm and
quiet and focus and when you meditate
you have a thought and you learn to
label that thought and put it out of
your head and deal with it later
so that when you're with a friend and
they're talking you're not thinking
about your next thought you put your
thought aside and you listen entirely to
what they're saying you focus on one
thing which is them and you are not
present until your friend at the end
end of the conversation says to you
thank you for listening I feel heard
thank you for being present with me
[Music]